hello sophia
hey roz how are you i'm really great how
are you doing i'm doing great i wish i
was with you i love canada i know i wish
you were here we're doing a lot of these
uh how is this week for you knowing what
is sort of at the end of it
tremendously exciting
and happy and i feel like
my smile is kind of stuck on my face in
the best way and um
it's a big week you know i've
had the joy and the pleasure of having a
a beautiful career in music and
releasing multiple singles and
soundtracks but to
release my debut album the story in my
heart just feels
different and
really exciting and emotional
uh calling it uh sophia carson
self-titled album was this always
something you wanted to do when back in
the years when you would dream of one
day putting out an album
i have been dreaming of what my album is
going to be called since i could
remember and i had a list of names as
you could imagine and when i finished
the record and i sat down
to name it
everything clicked all of a sudden
because to me my music
is my heart these songs
are part of who i am and so it made
sense for this album to be self-titled
it's like i'm sharing a piece of my
heart with the world
and uh why now why was now the right
time for a full album
it's a great question
a couple of things i think the pandemic
gave me the opportunity to dive into my
music heart and soul and to
write the story that was in my heart
that had begun writing many years ago
but i was able to have the time to fully
focus on that and i think my my career
has come to a point after the films and
the singles that i've released i just
felt time to release a body of work and
say this is who sophia carson is
so what is that story what is the story
that you wanted to tell
i wrote my first song when i was 10
and i always knew that when i wrote my
first album i would write a story from
start to finish a story about love
and i wrote a story about a girl who
falls
into a beautiful but deceiving love only
to get shattered but the story about a
girl who survives
and is this was the inspiration for this
all those years ago something that you
had
gone through even when you know those
sort of like first loves um where did
this all start your sort of fascination
with this is going to be the story i
tell
i have been in love with writing about
love since before i was in love
it just always fascinated me but of
course as
i've grown as a woman and as an artist
i've had my own experiences and love and
that's what informed this album my own
experiences as well as the experiences
of the people closest to me
but i kind of wrote this movie that i
wanted to bring to life
yeah and uh
le with loud loud has sort of taken on
this life of it it was instantaneously
empowering and was that the goal
yes
this song was
is meant to be dedicated to all of the
women of the world and all of the loud
voices have changed i feel
so honored to be a part of a generation
that is making history
by the fearless voices of women who are
shattering glass ceilings one loud voice
at a time and loud is dedicated to them
a celebration of them and the power of
our voices and like you said it's been
beautiful to watch the song take on a
life of its own and become a movement
and especially we wanted to release it
right before women's month which is also
the best month of the year but um it's
just been a perfect celebration of women
and i know you have a
an incredibly
close relationship with your mom what
has it been like sort of leading up to
this moment when the album is you know
almost out loud is doing so well to be
able to share all of this with her
sharing this with my mom and with my
sister and with my family
is magical you know my mom believed in
her little girl with a dream when she
was three years old dancing around her
house and putting on shows and she's
been the wind beneath my wings and my
end all be all and she'll be here this
week when the album comes out on friday
and i can't wait just
to hold her hand and say that we did it
success doesn't change
everything and there's one thing that
you notice a lot and that is regardless
of how many albums how many shows how
many movies there's still that part of
you that just wants to make somebody
proud
and uh and is that your is that your mom
you still strive to make her proud even
though it is without question already
there
absolutely i think that's a beautiful
way of saying it i do strive to make her
proud you know she has dedicated her
life and her heart and soul to me and to
my sister
and um i strive to make her proud in
everything that i do
uh unicef really quickly because i know
you're involved with this with the keep
girls in school campaign why
specifically this part of unicef with
keeping girls in school
goes back to my mom again my mom always
raised my sister and i to believe that
as women
the most important thing that we can do
is use our voices to give
and i have always gravitated towards
using my voice to empowering young women
because i believe wholeheartedly that
there is no greater force in the world
than an educated young woman
and there are millions and millions of
girls around the world who are out of
school whose voices whose futures have
been silenced and
unfairly removed and so
i'm so honored that this month i get to
partner with a unicef family with this
psa using loud to fight to keep girls in
school an act that will help to reduce
the barriers that girls face around the
world in accessing an education
uh being a being someone who inspires
others um you have to have something you
have to have something that inspires you
in order to be that for other people
what is it the thing that gets you to
that level
it's a great question
i would say it always goes back to to
giving to knowing that
i have this beautiful responsibility of
a voice and a platform that can make an
impact that can change even just one
life in one corner of the world and
everything that i do
every decision that i make every song
that i write and role that i play is
informed by that
and it makes me really happy to know
that i have that privilege
um purple hearts on netflix uh in it
producing it writing music for it
were people sick of you because you were
everywhere
you know what i have to ask the cast and
the crew
i hope not
i hope not um yeah this was an
incredible experience and definitely an
amazing step um for me as an artist to
be able to produce a film to be a part
of the writing process
of the script the character development
starring in it and then writing a
soundtrack with justin tranter who wrote
with me from my album and who's one of
the most iconic pop writers of our time
and
i
i'm beaming to share this project with
the world
and uh writing with this and then the
the writing work you did on your album
there's a certain confidence that you
have to have to
put yourself out there like that
um was that always there for you or is
it something you had to build up to
i think um
because of the woman that raised me and
how i was raised to believe that nothing
was impossible
i've always been confident
and i really owe that to my mom because
my sister and i both have a strong sense
of self
and um i think that's a blessing but of
course we always struggle with it we're
all human but um i think it all comes
down to the self-love that was kind of
instilled in me at a young age
uh when you sit down to write a song for
a movie does that change the way
you want to write something it does and
uh and and in what way
you know when you write a song for a
movie
you are not telling your own story but
you're telling a story through a
character's
eyes heart soul
so um it was for me i was terrified
going into it at first i was like who
trusted me to do this like what but then
you know i had to just let go and
believe in myself and trust and i had
gotten to know cassie my character so
well throughout the years and developing
her so i felt like i really knew who she
was and i knew her heart and justin was
just the most incredible partner and
together we really wrote her story but
it was a very different experience i
mean i obviously still
have a piece of myself in each of the
songs but i wasn't writing as sophia i
was writing as cassie
um what's do you have a favorite song
from a movie
in general yeah yeah
hmm
oh my gosh that's i can't i don't know i
i cause their their favorite soundtrack
is moulin rouge because that's one of my
favorite movies yeah perfect um but i'm
now blanking
you
well no i would say um god what was it
was it oh oh what am i saying
i think maybe madonna lived to tell from
vision quest with matthew mullen wait i
love that that's amazing that's one of
my mom's favorites too yeah i think that
that would be that's my favorite sort of
like movie specific song from from a
huge artist i think that that i would
say
that's a beautiful one mine is lady gaga
soundtrack for star is born which was
actually a huge inspiration for me going
into the writing of purple hearts but
that that finale song i'll never love
again just destroys me every single time
but that entire soundtrack is just
breathtaking
there aren't any features on your record
but i'm sure you have a bucket list of
people you would love to work with um
who's on that list
you know i've had the privilege
throughout my career to collaborate with
some of the biggest djs in the world
fiesta rehab allen
and alan walker and with this record i
wanted it just to be sophia but i do
have
you know obviously
i admire taylor swift immensely and ed
sheeran and then say i think they are
just some of the greatest songwriters in
the world so we'll put it out into the
universe